welcome to this video playing w stewart
I said Williams good okay didn't you
have another I'm kind of wondering
didn't do you have another account
anyway let's see what happens we get
there if you had shadow kings in it
again the 96 line is immensely popular
nowadays but quite sure why I mean not
that I'm saying it's bad it's just there
are many other possible lines and not
quite sure why exactly this is so
popular yeah I know that 9065 now it's
not particularly great but if you ask me
why I'm kind of failing I had this
before NM in a game okay I can take now
that's one little point of that move
water
yeah knight takes Bishop b2 is a
position that I like and if he takes
with the pawn that wouldn't feel very
logical I had this kind of positions
quite a lot from the symmetrical English
and always felt that I'm I'm all right
simple idea often is to just put a
knight on d5 and ask black what is doing
about it Bishop f5 whoo-hoo interesting
what about this move if I go 95 now 11
idea is Knight takes d5 Bishop g7 93
this is some sometimes some pretty funky
combination down okay I'm just going
Queen d2 94 is not really helping like a
lot you're bullying Stewart I once did a
video video for his channel i think it's
been a while I think the channel has
since renamed think it's called I chest
nowadays i'm not mistaken he's going for
that trades but not sure if it helps
them so much okay is there any point and
not taking they're probably not some
brighter take here his bishop is
unprotected sometimes there are tactics
but probably not here
going to settle for the idea to play mc5
Queen 85 looks very decent may be going
out of that d file it's surprising
really isn't c5 good for me I mean d5
cannot really be great and otherwise I'm
going to take on d6 amazing and even 94
is interesting now 1 95 95 Knight takes
bishop e4 isn't that almost winning what
is he doing there Bishop before looks
like the doctor looks excellent for
white that I didn't even consider I can
take here right and now desperado only
seven and then at the end see if I was
saying ok very sloppy calculation
Jack it's still a good position but not
sure what I was thinking okay rook c1
the pretty awkward isolated power course
now maybe queen is seven min queen d 6 I
can even go fo I'd win the point of me
and then 2755 Queenie for a little trick
okay so i can go in for the only
question is do I want to something like
QD for Luke c5 is also pretty strong not
sure i right that's the Queen D Phi
keeping it to and out for Roxy 5 Queenie
fights not completely solving his
problems as my looks are far more active
and the e4 pawn is a weakness and then
the minute I had that also helps of it
so he gives up a pawn that's probably
since sensible takes takes Queen d525
group t5 Roxy to a form now that leads
to four against three probably so it's
not not really that great but not sure
if I can really get much more in this
position
I doubt it so let's grab that pole and
play that rook endgame yeah yep a 4b 4d
for is probably good for white but you
can take a way to place that okay it's
not it's not a big issue I'm still going
to be four against three very lightly
okay see doing this no I was starting
with this move you should probably play
h5 now to make sure that g4 is not
happening so he allowed this and it was
a good good opportunity for that move so
I can do this first yeah there are a
couple of ways to press wide with four
against three and this is what we're
going to get and this is a position
where I can try mmm do I want to do this
first I'm not try morning jack maybe I
can annoy him a little bit here
okay so yeah I'm going to take it let's
see f3e for looking at four so there
anyway that's probably not going to work
let's do the draw it's still a draw
check
check check check check check check
check check okay I tricked him but it
was a draw check check check gluck for
fits on time yeah it was still a us to
draw even though he allowed the g4 did
you fall push yeah probably I have to
play some what to avoid this I really
can't believe that that I didn't get
more out of this the comp wants to do
this it leads to the same position but
it gives night before here yeah there's
some object to that just attacking d5
like this now that's better let's just
better 95 is pretty awkward and here I
can keep this and threaten f3 it's
pretty strong but we had the same thing
that now I could change didn't see that
mere may be here it can also play more
precisely for wins the porn but I felt
that I should press more orbit he
defended as well getting checked into
that NK
I think the only thing that he could
have done a little bit better was here
in this position he should he should go
h5 and make sure that I'm not even
getting in g4 it makes the defense a
little bit simpler but it was still at
all jagged wrong and don't get into one
of the winning positions that are that
unknown could have reached one don't
think so Jay yeah i mean i was trying
but check check this is really just a
draw chat yet no time what service
that's the issue here check wow that
that's very cool that's very cool he's
not losing here but not with seven
seconds on the clock he can play this
amazing movement chant very cute defensa
stalemate and this he gets all the stuff
back great stuff very nice very nice so
this this he could have still done of
course well he had no time whatsoever
okay well thanks for watching